it was pretty incredible as I was saying
to someone else I was speaking to just
now so many of us knew each other from
you know Margo and azo and I from New
York from the theater community and rose
as well and Kate I've worked there's a
third time I've worked with her
Liz Banks I know from Los Angeles it's
just a big big group of people that all
kind of knew each other so it was like
every every day somebody's first day
came around and we were all so excited
to see each other and to see their
transformation and that was a real
extraordinary part of this too was
watching everybody transform well I had
I had less of a responsibility in terms
of I'm not playing an iconic character
that many audiences might have
attachments to identifying immediately
so I had a little bit more leeway in
that regard but we had an incredible
costume designer named bina who who
really you know some of you watched
period pieces that everybody looks like
they're wearing a costume for a play it
doesn't feel like what people were
really wearing then and this this
doesn't have that at all partly due
mostly due to our extraordinary hair and
makeup and costume departments really
unbelievable yeah when you watch it
feels like you're being teleported back
into the 70s yeah well I I couldn't
bring myself back to it because I was
born then but thank you I'm just born in
74 so I don't remember any of it it's a
in a cogent way because I was my brain
was still forming but you know but the
thing I think and they talked about this
a bit on the panel which is that you
know one thing that happens a lot in a
movie when you especially when you go
back to the 70s which is an era that
like people love all the movies and all
the movements that were happening the
change that was happening in the country
is it sometimes looks like you're
looking at it through a lens from today
and you're sort of looking at a 1970s
style or look where is this thing it was
like what were they really doing what
did it really look like and not trying
to do a sort of beautiful version of it
for the sake of beauty but really
looking for authenticity which i think
is pretty cool
yeah and in Carroll twice Evan yeah yeah
oh god I would love to get an oceans
nine I feel like it would have to see if
awkwafina's available she's such a huge
star now it's like what are we gonna do
probably everybody's just waiting on
awkwafina's availability I mean Rock
FINA Nora what's what gives you're too
famous now like what you know who knows
we'll have to wait we'll have to wait
for her I don't know I don't know I
would love to do another one was a good
time Oh God to do a project with them I
just would like to meet them and thank
them for being such mindful citizens of
the world so that I would like to do
yeah thank you so much
[Music]